هل تشعل الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
الشراره حرب اهليه شيشانيه جديده الرئيس
شيشاني رمضان قديره زج بنفسه في مشهد صراع
الروسي الاوكراني يفتخر تاره بنشر قوته في
اوكرانيا استجابه لمطالب الرئيس الروسي
بلادي مربوطن وتاره اخرى يحض الاوكرانيين
على الاطاحه بحكمتهم
وحدهم من استقطبتهم الحرب فهناك على الضفه
الاخرى شيشانيون مناهضون لقديره وجدوه في
الحرب الدائره على اراضي اوكرانيا فرصه
للقتال ضد روسيا التي يعتبرونها عدوهم
الاول قبل نحو 22 عاما كان شيشانيون
يخوضون حربهم الاخيره من اجل استقلال
بلادهم عن روسيا حرب انتهت دون ان تحقق
اهدافها بالنسبه الى الجمهوريه القوقازيه
بل ادت الانقسام الشيشانيين الى فريقين
فريق الاول استسلم للحكم الروسي وان صاع
لسيطره رئيس البلاد الجديد رمضان قدير
وفريق ثاني حافظ على عدائه للرؤوس مواصلا
مواجهاته معهم على طريقه حرب العصابات
شكل هؤلاء المعارضون الشيشانيون النواه
الاولى لنقل الصراع الداخليه الشيشاني الى
شرق اوكرانيا وانخرطوا في صفوف الفرق
العسكريه من خلال كتيبتين اساسيتين كتيبه
جوهر دوايب وكتيبه الشيخ منصور
لكن اعدادا اخرى احجمت عن الانضمام الى
هذه الوحدات الاوكرانيه المقاتله خوفا من
عقوبات قانونيه لكونهم يحملون جنسيات دول
اوروبيه
في اوروبا وجدوا انفسهم هناك بعد الحربين
في الشيشان حصل معظمهم على جنسيته دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي
وان لم تلاحقهم عقوبات الدول الاوروبيه قد
يجدون انفسهم يواجهونه هم او اقاربهم
احتماليه الوقوع بيد قديره ومواجهه نهايه
الماساويه
من الشيشان من الذين يقاتلون مع
الاوكرانيين يخفون هوياتهم بسبب خوفهم على
اقاربهم ومن الاعدامات الجماعيه والقمع
بالنسبه لهؤلاء المقاتلين الشيشان الحرب
مساله شخصيه من جهه يقاتلون ابناء جلدته
من واقفين الى جانب روسيا وينظرون اليهم
كخونه ومن جهه اخرى لتصفيه حسابات قديمه
مع بوتن على امل ان تكون الحرب بدايه
النهايه لعدوهم القديم بوتن